Qui trouvez-vous la plus belle ?
Marilyn Monroe,
le sex-symbol hollywoodien des années 1950
à la sensualité généreuse,
ou Kate Moss,
l’icône de mode des années 1990-2000,
surnommée « la Brindille » ?
Donnez-moi votre opinion dans les commentaires.
Ce que montre la différence entre ces deux
femmes admirées pour leur beauté,
- que seules quelques dizaines d’années
séparent -
c’est que les repères esthétiques changent
avec le temps.
La beauté, elle aussi, aurait donc une histoire.
Je suis Romain,
et vous êtes sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
J’ai lu ce livre,
Histoire de la beauté de Georges Vigarello,
qui est un historien et sociologue français,
spécialiste du corps.
Il y montre comment la conception de la beauté
a épousé
– forcément –
les grandes dynamiques sociales, les ruptures
culturelles,
les conflits de genre et de génération.
Il fait commencer l’histoire de la beauté
au XVIe siècle,
parce que c’est à ce moment que s’accélère
la mutation des repères esthétiques.
Et vous verrez à la fin de la vidéo l’ampleur
des changements
qui sont intervenus en quelques siècles seulement.
Si j’avais une vidéo d’une femme du 16ème
siècle
et si je l’avais comparée à Kate Moss,
ça aurait été quelque chose...
Allez, je vous en parle,
de cette femme du 16ème siècle.
C’est donc la première beauté moderne
qui émerge au 16ème siècle,
notamment grâce aux artistes de la Renaissance,
qui décrivent le corps de manière plus réaliste
et qui sélectionnent leurs modèles de plus
en plus
en fonction de leur beauté.
Il y a trois éléments caractéristiques
de la beauté
à retenir pour cette période
- vous allez voir qu’ils vont fortement
évoluer avec les siècles.
Première chose :
la beauté,
eh bien c’est exclusivement la beauté de
la femme.
Malgré son infériorité sociale,
la belle femme est un idéal,
c’est pourquoi elle est souvent comparée
à une divinité
(surtout Vénus, la déesse romaine de la
beauté).
L’homme, lui,
est associé à des qualités qui ne relèvent
pas de l’esthétique,
comme la force, la dureté, la pilosité,
la fermeté, la solidité
- qualité qui sont toutes opposées à la
prétendue mollesse féminine.
Deuxième chose à retenir :
toutes les parties du corps ne comptent pas
autant dans la beauté
- loin de là.
En fait, il y a à l’époque une hiérarchie
dans le corps :
les parties hautes
- tout particulièrement le visage, jusqu’à
la gorge -
sont les plus importantes ;
ce sont elles qui font la beauté,
donc elles peuvent être découvertes.
Le bas, en revanche, n’est qu’un support,
un socle
- il est donc inutile de le mettre en valeur.
Au 16ème siècle,
les jambes de femmes sont occultées par les
robes à évasement,
et elles sortent du cadre des portraits.
En clair, les jambes ne comptent pas -
quel dommage.
Troisième élément important :
la beauté est indéfinissable ;
on n’a pas les mots pour la décrire avec
précision,
on reste dans le vague.
On la contemple comme une évidence,
comme si elle n’avait pas besoin d’être
pensée.
C’est surtout la religion, en fait,
qui impose sa conception de la beauté :
la femme ne doit pas user de son charme esthétique
pour séduire l’homme,
car sa beauté consiste en des qualités morales
:
elle doit rester modeste, humble, et chaste
- pas de quoi faire une couverture de magazine.
Elle peut éventuellement se maquiller
si ça l’aide à trouver un mari,
mais dans 99% des circonstances,
pas de maquillage,
parce que c’est l’oeuvre du diable.
Alors, petite conclusion partielle pour ce
siècle :
la belle femme a un beau visage blanc,
bien symétrique,
elle est très sérieuse,
mais elle est déjà un petit peu plus pulpeuse
que les modèles du Moyen Âge.
On se rapproche de Marilyn Monroe,
mais tout doucement.
Bien évidemment,
les choses ne changent pas du tout au tout
d’un siècle à l’autre,
donc il y a une certaine continuité.
La dimension sociale de la beauté perdure
:
les nobles valorisent la minceur,
qui symboliserait leur rectitude,
tandis que les gens du peuple sont ronds,
parce qu’ils seraient moralement trop relâchés.
Les stéréotypes des sexes perdurent également,
et l’artifice - notamment le maquillage
-
est toujours comme sous le coup d’un anathème
- avec la Contre-Réforme,
c’est même un peu la mode
d’abandonner ostensiblement le maquillage
en signe de retour à la dévotion.
Alors, malgré cette continuité,
l’expérience esthétique, elle, change.
La culture citadine rend la beauté plus quotidienne,
plus sociale.
On paraît dans les lieux de promenade pour
se jauger,
donc les repères de l’étiquette et du
maintien
prennent de l’importance.
L’idée sous-jacente à cette évolution,
c’est que la beauté exprime l’identité
intérieure,
ou l’âme si on veut.
Un beau visage est vif et animé,
et il l’est d’autant plus que le regard
réussit à transmettre quelque chose,
à produire une émotion.
Cette nouvelle idée,
la beauté comme reflet de l’âme,
perpétue la dimension mystérieuse de la
beauté,
ce « je ne sais quoi » qui la rend troublante.
Les vieilles catégories morales sont abandonnées
au profit d’une typologie psychologique
de la beauté :
les « beautés sévères », « fières », etc.
- d’où par exemple la mode du portrait
écrit,
qui consiste à mêler le physique et le moral.
Cette importance nouvelle des passions explique
le prestige grandissant du théâtre,
et la sensibilité des spectateurs au charme
de l’actrice.
MAIS En même temps,
la conception de la beauté est un peu désenchantée
par la théorie cartésienne du corps comme
machine.
Cette théorie popularise des dispositifs
préventifs,
tel le corset,
qui compriment les membres
et ont malheureusement beaucoup d’effets
indésirables
(sur le dos, la respiration, l'haleine, etc.).
En gros,
on essaie de réparer le corps
comme on réparerait une machine.
Et grâce à cette vision,
eh bien l’artifice gagne un peu plus en
légitimité.
Si le maquillage est réservé aux occasions
mondaines
- il est proscrit pour les veuves,
les vieilles femmes,
et plus globalement dans le privé -
il s’est quand même imposé.
Alors, comment décrire la belle femme du
XVIIe siècle ?
Elle a le regard plus expressif,
elle se montre davantage,
et elle est probablement un peu plus apprêtée.
C’est à partir du siècle suivant
que le corps commence à prendre plus de place
dans les repères esthétiques.
Le siècle des Lumières est celui d'une évolution
fondamentale :
ç’en est fini du fantasme d’une beauté
unique,
comme révélée par les dieux.
Le sensible et le caractère fonctionnel du
corps humain
deviennent désormais primordiaux dans le
jugement esthétique.
Le beau corps est désormais regardé,
analysé, disséqué
avec une débauche de critères empiriques.
Et le plus important de ces critères,
c'est la fonction naturelle de la beauté
:
elle favorise le plaisir individuel
en vue de la perpétuation de l’espèce.
Cette idée sera notamment évoquée par Schopenhauer
dans sa Métaphysique de l’amour,
à propos de laquelle j’ai fait une vidéo
- vous pouvez la voir en cliquant
sur le lien en haut à droite.
La beauté exprimerait donc, à l’échelle
individuelle,
une injonction de la nature.
Comme le dit Voltaire,
la beauté, pour un crapaud,
eh bien c’est simplement sa crapaude,
avec ses deux gros yeux ronds,
sa gueule et son ventre jeune de crapaude
- ça ne va pas plus loin.
Chez les humains,
on met surtout en valeur les hanches
qui renvoient à la fonction gestatrice de
la femme.
Cette pensée esthétique des Lumières a
plusieurs implications.
Premièrement,
la beauté quotidienne est plus libre :
les artifices qui s’opposaient au développement
naturel du corps sont dénoncés :
les corsets ne sont plus utilisés pour les
enfants,
et leur rigidité est atténuée pour les
femmes.
Deuxième implication :
on considère désormais que le corps doit
être non plus préservé,
mais stimulé naturellement,
par exemple avec en favorisant les influences
atmosphériques
(le climat, l'air, l'eau),
ou avec des soins aquatiques
pour densifier les fibres,
et plus généralement par l’exercice physique,
comme les promenades dites « hygiéniques
».
Troisième implication de la pensée esthétique
des Lumières :
le beau corps,
c’est, pour Rousseau notamment,
le corps sain du paysan, ou du sauvage,
à opposer au corps dégénéré du citadin.
En conclusion partielle,
la belle femme du XVIIIe siècle a des formes
plus maternelles,
et en même temps elle est plus active.
Une évolution qui commence à transparaître
également,
c’est la dimension individualiste de l’esthétique
:
la beauté est de moins en moins un idéal
absolu ;
elle se personnalise ;
elle devient le moyen,
par exemple avec la coiffure qui se développe,
d’exprimer une identité singulière.
L’évolution fondamentale de ce siècle
est que la beauté féminine devient plus
anatomique.
La perspective du siècle passé,
la nature,
est toujours là -
l’attention à la cambrure
et à la chute des reins renvoie à la fécondité
-
MAIS les lignes du corps sont regardées plus
dans le détail.
Les femmes les auscultent dans le miroir,
dans les cabinets de bain.
Leurs vêtements les mettent davantage en
valeur,
ou plutôt les dissimulent moins.
Dans le dernier quart du siècle, par exemple,
c’est la mode des robes collantes
qui affirment les hanches.
Les corsets deviennent beaucoup plus souples
;
ils ne font désormais plus qu’assister
la fermeté anatomique féminine
en misant sur une forme corporelle en S.
Et il y a même carrément des mouvements
d’opinion
qui dénoncent le corset,
notamment parce qu’il n’est pas du tout
adapté aux nouveaux métiers féminins
(des métiers de bureau, surtout).
Mais surtout,
la hiérarchisation des parties du corps évolue.
Les parties basses,
tels le bassin et l’amorce des cuisses,
sont de plus en plus prises en compte.
Du coup,
la beauté féminine devient plus érotique.
Les actrices sont de plus en plus sensuelles
et provocantes,
comme dans le Nana de Zola ;
le nu se normalise à la fin du siècle dans
les spectacles,
les affiches, et les journaux.
Enfin,
autre vecteur de l’érotisme féminin :
les vacances à la plage influencent les canons
de la beauté
en les américanisant.
Parallèlement,
les stéréotypes des siècles passés reculent.
L’esthétique féminine intègre un peu
un fantasme de liberté,
comme en témoigne la figure de la Parisienne
de la première moitié du siècle,
avide d’exercices et d’affairements,
à laquelle on reproche d’emprunter des
qualités masculines.
À l’inverse,
l’homme, lui, s’adoucit un peu,
- on lui demande désormais de mêler la grâce
à la vigueur.
C’est même à cette époque qu’émerge
en Angleterre le modèle du dandy,
qui incarne à l’extrême,
lui qui soigne profondément son apparence,
la nouvelle combinaison masculine de force
et de délicatesse.
Les stéréotypes à l’encontre des moyens
d'embellissement reculent aussi.
Les artifices sont désormais diffusés à
grande échelle,
comme si chacun avait un « droit à la beauté
».
En 1859,
Baudelaire emploie un nouveau mot,
le « maquillage »,
qu’il assimile à un art,
à un spectacle mystérieux.
C'est en effet devenu une architecture savante,
où se combinent les couleurs,
les couches,
et les niveaux.
Sur le plan économique se constitue
un véritable marché de l’embellissement,
avec des « produits de beauté
et des « soins de beauté »
surdifférenciés par les marques,
promus agressivement par la publicité qui
mobilise ambassadrices et vedettes,
et vendus en masse dans des grands magasins
dépeints par Zola dans Au bonheur des dames.
Seulement,
tout le monde ne peut pas encore s’offrir
ces produits ;
mais le pouvoir de la mode est si grand
que certaines femmes vont jusqu’à se prostituer
pour s’offrir une paire de gants.
Ce marché de l’embellissement,
ce sont aussi les régimes qui se multiplient,
les instituts de beauté de plus en plus nombreux,
et les débuts de la chirurgie esthétique.
Alors, comment décrire la belle femme du
XIXe siècle ?
Elle est beaucoup plus érotique :
elle a la poitrine galbée,
les fesses arrondies,
et une chevelure travaillée qui nourrit les
fantasmes ;
mais elle fait tout de même attention à
la minceur du bas du corps.
On est tout proche de la beauté Marilyn Monroe.
Comme ils sont encore en bonne partie les
nôtres,
on devine bien mieux les repères esthétiques
des démocraties contemporaines.
Ils sont le résultat de quatre évolutions
majeures.
La première est le développement du culte
de la minceur,
qui exprime en fait,
pour Georges Vigarello,
la pression sociale à l’efficacité et
à la flexibilité.
La silhouette féminine idéale a vraiment
changé
dans les années 1910-1920 :
la belle femme est dorénavant plus grande,
plus étirée,
légère, gracile,
et même musclée.
Pour atteindre cet idéal,
il faut bien sûr prendre régulièrement
des mesures ;
c’est pourquoi les mensurations envahissent
les magazines
et les traités de beauté à partir des années
1930.
Le poids idéal baisse très rapidement :
51kg en 1939, contre 60kg en 1929
pour une femme d’1m60
- donc ça fait moins 10 kilos en seulement
10 ans !
Enfin,
ce culte de la minceur a aussi paradoxalement
une dimension hédoniste,
avec le bronzage qui devient une mode
- il y a même des machines à UV dès les
années 1930 -
ou encore avec les concours de beauté
qui se multiplient dans l’entre-deux-guerres.
La deuxième évolution majeure de la période
c'est l’apparition de puissants modèles
esthétiques,
les stars.
Le cinéma - notamment hollywoodien -
décuple le charme de l’actrice,
qui a émergé au cours des siècles précédents.
La « photogénie »
(terme inventé dans les années 1920)
est donc une nouvelle qualité primordiale
de la beauté.
Les films montrent un visage parfaitement
maquillé,
avec des yeux qui s’agrandissent à l’infini,
et des cheveux d’une blondeur étincelante
à la lumière.
Les actrices des années 50-60
suscitent le désir du spectateur
en érotisant de nouvelles parties du corps
- les lèvres entrouvertes et renflées,
la poitrine rebondie -
comme Brigitte Bardot, par exemple,
qui joue des femmes affranchies
et provocantes.
Si les stars sont des modèles inaccessibles,
leurs exemples et leurs parcours inspirent
en même temps
un rêve esthétique social de masse
En fait,
l’exemple des stars diffuse la conviction
que la beauté récompense la discipline,
la culture physique, et le régime.
Or, cette conviction érige le corps
en objet de consommation.
Le marché de l’embellissement se développe,
et la production s’industrialise.
Les recherches se multiplient
et décalent les efforts :
en 1930, le magazine Vogue déclare la cellulite,
qui a été découverte seulement en 1920,
ennemi public n°1.
À la même époque naît une chirurgie purement
esthétique,
même si elle sert surtout corriger les rides
(ça représente 80% des opérations en 1930).
Mais la discipline va se développer et se
démocratiser,
si bien que 6% des femmes françaises
avaient déjà eu recours à la chirurgie
esthétique en 2000
(surtout pour la liposuccion).
Le business de la beauté bénéficie
de la multiplication de médiums.
Une femme sur deux achète des magazines en
1980,
de telle sorte que deux sur trois en lisent.
Le mannequinat se développe
pour accompagner la massification du marché
des artifices,
dont le volume est multiplié plusieurs fois
dans la seconde partie du siècle.
La dernière évolution majeure de la période,
c’est le bouleversement des genres.
L’érotisation de l’esthétique féminine
n’est plus anodine :
elle s’accompagne de la libération progressive
de la femme
dans sa vie intime et ses choix personnels.
Il y a en même temps une mutation esthétique
:
la belle femme des années 1980 prend des
traits androgynes ;
ses formes sexuées (les hanches, les seins)
sont gommées,
comme la mannequin française (égérie de
Chanel) Inès de la Fressange,
ou encore comme Kate Moss,
dont j’ai parlé tout au début.
Mais la beauté masculine subit une évolution
comparable.
Assumant des traits féminins,
l’homme de la fin du XXe siècle est dit
« métrosexuel ».
Georges Vigarello donne en exemple
le personnage de Neo dans le film Matrix,
qui a un corps très longiligne,
alors que sa partenaire, Trinity,
est elle plutôt masculine.
Il évoque aussi le visage lisse de David
Beckham,
dépourvu des aspérités
qui symbolisaient la dureté masculine.
C’est dans une certaine mesure la culture
gay
qui a contribué à transposer au masculin
les repères esthétiques et les artifices
féminins.
Au total,
l’égalité a fait de la beauté une qualité
aussi masculine que féminine
– le thème du « beau sexe » a disparu.
Mais surtout,
un seuil crucial a été imperceptiblement
franchi :
le bas du corps compte désormais plus que
le haut.
Scary Movie sac sur la tête
Les repères esthétiques ont donc profondément
évolué depuis la Renaissance.
Qu’en retenir, en synthèse ?
Je crois que trois évolutions sont particulièrement
fondamentales.
La première,
c’est que la totalité du corps a été
progressivement
prise en compte dans la beauté,
et que la hiérarchie originelle s’est même
inversée
- même si le visage compte toujours 😃
La deuxième évolution,
c’est la libération des codes de l’apparence
:
l’individu peut désormais les déterminer
par lui-même.
Les vieux stéréotypes ont disparu,
les repères sont très émiettés
- l’individu peut adopter une esthétique
plus ou moins féminine,
ou masculine,
faire son choix parmi les multiples modèles
disponibles,
qui changent sans cesse de look
- qu’ils viennent du cinéma, du sport,
de la téléréalité,
et maintenant des réseaux sociaux.
Enfin la troisième évolution,
liée à la seconde,
c’est que la beauté n’est plus un destin,
mais un projet.
Les modèles qui déterminent les repères,
des icônes hollywoodiennes aux modèles d’Instagram,
entretiennent une émulation esthétique,
qui balance l’individu contemporain
entre l’épanouissement
et la crispation.
Qu’on pense à l’incroyable paradoxe des
régimes :
alors qu’ils sont très populaires,
ils sont statistiquement voués à l’échec
- moins de 40 % réussissent à court/moyen
terme,
et moins de 25 % à long terme
(c’est-à-dire au-delà de cinq ans).
Pourquoi l’individu persiste-t-il, alors
?
Le fin mot de l’histoire,
c’est que la démarche esthétique
est en réalité une quête d’identité.
Trouver et construire sa beauté,
c’est, pour l’individu moderne,
se trouver soi-même.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo,
mettez un pouce bleu
et abonnez-vous à la chaîne
pour être prévenu de la sortie de la suivante.
Pour lire mon article de blog inspiré de
ce livre,
L’Histoire de la beauté de Georges Vigarello,
voire pour lire le livre lui-même,
tous les liens sont dans la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Pour recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale
synthétisées dans le format le plus clair
possible,
vous pouvez vous inscrire à la newsletter
en laissant votre adresse e-mail sur le site.
Je suis Romain
et sous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous vous n’avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête
pour vous intéresser au meilleur de la pensée.